hey everyone it's Mike from orderflows
here and welcome back to my channel in
this video I'm going to discuss Delta
reversals and exhaustion prints now you
know when you talk about Delta reversals
there's different types of uh reversals
that can be seen in the Delta and
specifically I'll be talking about uh
the orderflows Delta Divergence tool as
well as the exhaustion print tool now
before I jump into it you know if you've
been enjoying my videos be sure to
subscribe to the channel and hit the
like button and don't forget to hit that
notification button so that whenever I
post a new video you'll be notified and
you can uh swoop in and watch it all
right
so what is a Delta Divergence all right
so a Delta Divergence is you know
something let let me take a step back
here so when you think of a market
moving up you generally expect to see it
moving up on positive Delta why is
because the market is exhibiting a
aggressive buying right and if you have
net positive Delta in a bar you're going
to have positive Delta just as if a
market is selling off you're going to
have net aggressive selling you know
generally the bars are going to be red
right they're going to be um negative
Delta on the way down now when you hit a
high and you have aggressive selling
coming in right that's important to you
as an orderflow Trader because hey you
know what I'm going higher I've hit a
high now I got aggressive selling coming
in that could be your potential for a
reversal just as if you're going lower
right you're going to see red Deltas you
know negative Deltas negative Delta is
all on the way down as you're making new
lows but if you get to a low and all of
a sudden you see positive Delta right a
nice green candle with positive Delta
that's a sign that hey you know what
price is reversed right price Action Now
is bullish because you got a green
candle and Delta is bullish right you
got aggressive buyers stepping into the
market dominating the aggressive Sellers
and that is one way to define a Delta
reversal now Delta reversal by itself or
Delta Divergence by itself sometimes is
just is not enough right because if you
have say a trending market up or down
you know you're going to get profit
taking you know if if the market keeps
rallying making new highs making new
highs people are going to take money off
the table they're going to come in
they're going to exit their positions
and you're going to be left with you
know a red candle with negative Delta at
the high of the day or just as if a
Market's been selling off you know
traders that are short you know they
want to take their money off the table
book some profits you know they'll come
in and start buying to cover their
shorts right and often times you're
going to see you know that green candle
you know at the low with positive Delta
then the market just continues on down
right because why because whoever was
taking profits you know is they took
their profits and now the market is just
going to continue to do what it's going
to do right often times it can go lower
now how can you improve your chances of
having a successful trade with you know
a Delta Divergence is use another aspect
of order flow right since you're using
Delta Divergence as a reversal sign look
at another aspect of order flow that is
a reversal um signal right and
exhaustion prints is one that when
combined with Delta Divergence is quite
powerful okay because what happens with
the exhaustion print well if the
Market's going up and you have an
exhaustion print at a high well it's
telling you the last buyer has bought
just as if the market was selling
off and the last seller has sold right
you're going to end often end up with an
exhaustion print at that low right why
because there's no more sellers
interested in in selling right and now
what you've attracted when the market
made that low is the buyers coming in so
when you combine Delta Divergence which
is a delta form of Delta reversal with
exhaustion print right it sets you up
for very nice trading opportunities okay
and you know if you
watch a footprint right you can see
exhaustion prints forming right it's
what it is it's it's thin volume at the
bottom of bars or at the top of bars
right top of red bars or bottom of green
bars you're looking at the volume that's
traded on the footprint so for example
here right we have this Market made a
swing low this is crude oil right now it
doesn't matter what Market you're
trading doesn't matter what chart type
you're using you know volume is volume
and if it appears on one chart often
it's going to appear on you know other
charts right I'm going to show you uh
you know several different markets in
this video so what do we have here also
we have a swing low right it's not the
low of the day it's a swing low with
positive Delta so I know aggressive
buyers stepped in at this swing low
right and I have an exhaustion print now
if you're just looking at a footprint
right you have to train yourself to see
this and you know many Traders have
right that's why it's such a powerful
form of orderflow analysis now you know
with the Advent
of you know personal computers you know
everyone's got a personal
computer sometimes people got several of
them um you know you could get software
to highlight this to you so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to show you the
orderflows trader software which is a
software I developed to show the
exhaustion print
okay now you know this is crude oil so
it doesn't trade as much as you know
equities so I'm going to make the
exhaustion print volume uh a little bit
lower I just I put it down at five okay
and I wanted to show me the exhaustion
prints okay now right so I enable that
right it's going to show me the
exhaustion Prints but you know is an
exhaustion print at this low is another
exhaus print another exhaus another
another another well I'm not interested
right because I'm trying to trade a
reversal right CU I'm trying to trade
exhaustion print reversal and a Delta
Divergence reversal so what I'm going to
do
is I'm going to go back to the settings
okay and I'm going to click on use swing
filter okay now you know I'm going to
default is set to five but I'm going to
make it a little bit stronger I'll make
it 10 a swing period of 10 so it's going
to find
you know swing highs or swing lows over
a 10 bar period and click apply okay so
what you're going to see now right now
it's cleaned it up a lot so I I just see
this exhaustion print at the swing low
which is what I'm interested in okay and
again you know you can see there was one
here um you know there was one here as
well all right but uh now I'm going to
add the second piece the Delta reversal
right which is the Delta Divergence now
in the orderflows trader right you go
under Delta Divergence okay now there's
two settings right if you just want to
see the Delta Divergence coming in at
the high of the day or the low of the
day you would just keep the only daily
high or daily low enabled but what I'm
trying to do is I'm trying to find swing
highs or swing lows that have both a
Delta Divergence as well as an
exhaustion print okay so I'm going to
enable the swing filter here now this
swing filter is link linked up to this
swing period up here of 10 right which
is the same period that I'm using on my
exhaustion print
okay then I'm going to click
apply and you can see right here this
yellow or gold color actually right with
the exhaustion
print okay this was just an exhaustion
print but but no Divergence this was a
Divergence with no exhaustion print this
was just a Divergence by
itself see if got anything else this was
just a Divergence by itself this was
just the Divergence by itself down here
is a nice uh exhaustion Print Plus a
Divergence okay and you see these are
very strong moves the market came down
to that level kept rallying up so you
know what are you're doing you're
filtering out the divergences that
aren't necessarily effective and you're
filtering out the exhaustion prints that
aren't that effective now you know some
people going to say wow you know this is
got a lot of lines here and stuff you
know they're not they're not interested
what you could do
is there's a couple
things let me just show you something
here okay you would just go to if you
don't want to see the zone right what
you do is you just uh make it fixed
here and make this one
fixed and then all you're going to do
right you're just going to look for
those
instances where you have the two little
triangles here where you have the
green little box there and the golden
zone so the two the gold and the green
here okay this is just green that's just
gold that's just
green that's just
gold this is green and gold here okay
now if you wanted to you could make it
even bigger if you just want you're just
looking at these plots here let me just
show you here what you got to do is you
just go down in
here
find exhaustion print okay you make it
bigger from four make it say
eight
eight and Delta Divergence Buy Signal
Delta Divergence sell signal make that
eight eight as well okay
right so you can see right here right it
just stands out it's very clear
now some Traders say you know what I
don't want to look at an orderflow
footprint chart right to look at this I
just want to see it on my normal bar
chart there is a way you can do that
right and you know the thing is with the
orderflows trader right it's going to
show you both instances whether there's
a Delta Divergence or an exhaustion
print or both Delta Divergence and an
exhaustion print now
um have developed another tool for
Traders you know cuz you know I'm a
Trader I like to
trade it's called the orderflows toolbox
so here let me just uh pull up a chart
really quick go change this to a simple
Candlestick
chart okay and I'm going to load this
tool it's called the
toolbox Okay click apply here
just uh
Hey a what's going on
here
[Music]
toolbox got the wrong template up
here okay I uh blitzed out there for a
second here so make sure I got tick
replay
on then I'm going to add the toolbox I
just loaded the wrong template um
click on toolbox here
okay so toolbox is loaded so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to add the same
things here Delta Divergence I'm going
to take off the daily high and daily low
and I'm going to add the exhaustion
prints right I was using
five okay I'm going to make the swing
filter 10 right CU that was my swing
filter so
10 Delta Divergence and exhaustion
prints okay one other little
thing I'll just turn off this trade
entry signal real quick
here and you can see here let me get the
crosshairs up right there's one
here right this is the one from earlier
that I showed
you this is the one earlier in the day
couple here small moves right and you
know that's crude oil I mean you can
look at other markets gold and gold is a
nice Market to trade similar to crude
you could use sort of the same
settings okay just scrunch this chart up
a bit here but you could see
okay bearish bullish bearish bearish
bullish bearish a
small this one didn't work out this one
didn't work out but you got a nice
little move here doesn't look like much
but this is a move from you know
basically
70 you know what is that
2679 down to 7 that's a $200 move there
this is a nice little move up little
move down you this one you know that's
already 3 in the
afternoon but you can see right this is
uh Delta Divergence and exhaustion print
all right so it's it's a
pretty strong trade setup that you could
look for again if if you're using a
normal footprint chart it's great if you
want to use something called the the
toolbox the link is below in the
description and that's all I got to say
on this video so again you know if you
like this video U be sure to hit the
Subscribe button and if you like what I
put out be sure to hit that notification
button so that when I do post a new
video you know you'll be notified so
take care everyone I'll see you guys on
the next video